hello and welcome to this video will
playing our cold chew on Poland oh wow
only played blitz but 3,000 games that's
a lot okay that's not a line the pulse
is not one of the lines that I have
practiced very hard after admit don't
get it so often usually c6 is a signal
move for me to push a form does it going
to play e5 one of those moves that I
have a hard time to believe that they
should work at all with white line up
against their self let's see what
happens
so let's say I'm castling and he goes
Knight f6 that is probably we also have
to think about 95-year immediately
hmm yeah I'm trying to refute this which
is probably not possible mmm it looks
pretty bad but you can probably not
refute it straight away at least not in
a blitz game seem
so we can cannot take take take stakes
and you cannot move a piece as I have
seven is hanging this is what I meant
with ever our time to believe that this
should work in the first place because
blacks position is hanging by a thread
really but maybe it is it's still
working
okay what about this Bishop D form you
know that looks like look strong yeah
maybe this is actually doing the trick
what is he doing now Queen to e7 Queen
f3 that looks awful
don't really see something here Queen f3
what's going on when II five is also a
strong move huh I'm not quite sure
what's better Queen f3 Bishop g4 Bishop
f6 yeah looks winning on the other hand
he 5 also looks like it's killing 595
bishop on takes Knight takes
and it's also disaster
yeah not sure what's better both looks
both moves look absolutely killing if he
does not go to d5 I just have rook f7
and it wins everything so 95 is forced
Bishop takes Bishop takes Knight takes
Knight takes c6 that that then was what
took me a bit of time there he six
should should should kill I can also
take g7 first yeah I'm taking this first
yeah the time but it's just it's just
too much the rook is too much the chick
first
know that if things go wrong and those
openings with practical really wrong
okay I was not really seeing I mean II
five looks really bad I mean it looks
like completely wrong in terms of timing
I played Bishop c4 which is actually
liked by the comp now that I think of it
I just wonder I could have just taken
twice and it looks pretty strong as well
I mean that position sucks for black for
sure okay Bishop c4 doesn't seem to be
bad I mean it looks very logical and
looking at that you played Queen e7 and
now Knight g5 is strong hmm I thought
about it but I couldn't quite see what
to do here okay the computer wants to do
this threatening d6 I guess that is
strong it's really strong okay but
castles wasn't bad either and now on the
night and I think what I did is good
right our F takes is stronger even yeah
okay the other way around is probably
stronger him and now it took only five
if he cancels it soon as some kind of
game but he is just it's just completely
over
five is stronger than Queenie of three
okay yeah I thought that should win
there's castles aha there is canceled
I didn't even see that yeah the point is
simply this this this and I'm dropping
this back so you okay what I was seeing
is that this was just killing when the
night has only one square d5 and then
saw that here after the Queen back move
I have a six and that's all wrong and
then then I played it there's just
nothing there if he takes it we have a
double attack basically on the rook
night here east sevens or everything at
the same time castling a key seven is
just devastating and we had almost the
same thing like here is seven and it
wins just everything yet if those
openings go wrong for black they go
really wrong here probably be five I
mean it's kind of clear that white
should have an advantage but this is
probably what what black yeah I should
do I go a 3m as the engine suggests as
well then Bishop d3 castles short and I
mean why it must be better here okay
guys thanks for watching